Chúng ta có hội dưới nhận nhiều kết quả nổi bật thử dân qua, trong đó có việc lãnh đạo
cuối hội chực tiếp làm việc của ý thường trực hội đồng dân tộc.
Các bạn của cuối hội và văn phòng cuối hội để chỉ đạo trên khai các nghiệm
vụ trọng tâm lòng hàng nghị hủ trong hệ sấu và cả những kỳ cuối hội khoảng
hệ sấu. Cần chương thực hiện kế hoạch số sống mới tư của ý bán thường
vụ cuối hội. Chỉnh khai kênh lượng xuống bị bài của bộ chính trị và để
an định vướng là pháp nhận kỳ cuối hội khoảng hệ sấu.
Nhận mạnh nhận vụ trong tâm thẳng sấu năm hàng nghị hủ trong hệ sấu,
chú thì cuối hội khẳng định mục tiêu tăng trường 2 con số là mạnh lệ chính trị
và lạc kỳ vọng của nhân dân trong vụ thành đó.
Công tăng lập pháp và có chuyện biến mạnh mẽ chuyển tư tư dưới quả nỉ đến đâu
cuối định đến đó, săng tư dưới kiến tạo phát triển kệ sốt rử dò và thu dẩy đổi mời sáng tạo.
Chú thì cuối hội yếu cầu cân tập trung cao đổi chính khai kế hoạch số sấu tư.
Chú đồng phối hội thẩm chá các giãn lột khi quét pháp lệ chính trình kỳ hội thứ 2,
đông thời, truy bị sẵn sàng cho kỳ hội chuyên đề về sử dựng pháp lột nếu thực biến đặt ra yếu cầu.
Bên cảnh đó, cân đề nháng tinh độ tổng ra soát hiện thống văn bản cuối pháp lột,
báo cáo định kỳ hai tổng một lần để kiếp thời phát hiện,
kiến nghị sử li các quy định trồng chéo, mô thuận hoặc không còn của hợp.
Cần trường hoàn thiện hồ sơ sử dòi cuối trế là việc của y伴 từ hủ khội,
khi quyết sổ đồng hai thứ văn nghi quyết sử dòi làm,
một giả vụ quan trọng khác được chú tí cuối hội nhấn mạnh,
là tiếp tục khoản thiện tổ chức bộ mấy,
đần cao chất lượng lượng của cán bộ,
đông thời các giãn quy trình thủ tục giúp ngãn thời gian giản giữ li công việc.
Chú tí cuối hội nhấn mạnh,
tư nãy đến cuối năm, khối lượng công việc còn rất lớn,
cho khi yêu cầu ngày càng cao,
đều còn trọng nhất lúc này là biến quyết tâm thành hành động,
biến chương trình thành kích quả,
biến nhập vụ được giáo thành sản phẩm của thế,
đỏ điểm được và mang lại giả trị thức trọng nghe rân,
lần nhập và sự phát triển của đần nước.